next time you stop at a gas station
think of it as a 100 a month tax cut or
maybe a 100 a month raise
that is a verbatim suggestion from cnn
which goes on to report quote a one
dollar decrease in gas prices equals
about 125 billion dollars a year in
savings for u.s households or more than
10 billion dollars a month that's equal
to about a half of a percentage point on
the nation's gross domestic product the
broadest measure of economic activity
and that's just a direct benefit lower
diesel prices bring down the cost of
transportation for all goods including
food if you add in the indirect benefits
it's real money
real money
in our pockets all because the price of
gas has gone down on joe biden's watch
thanks joe
except of course
that it hasn't
it just hasn't it's just not true the
price of gas has increased substantially
on joe biden's watch it's up almost 65
percent since the day he took office and
that's with him draining the national
strategic petroleum reserve through the
midterm elections after that it's going
to go right back up again
this article from cnn
this very article by what's his name
chris isadore
this would make a north korean news
anchor blush
pravda at the height of the cold war
would think twice
about running this kind of ridiculous
propaganda
that is too much you have gone too far
comer and
and yet cnn has absolutely
no shame
in the old soviet union at least pravda
admitted that it was the communist party
paper in the u.s our allegedly intrepid
and independent press runs this kind of
nonsense on a daily basis the only
difference is that cnn
and the new york times and the
washington post and all the networks and
on and on the entire establishment media
apparatus doesn't even have the decency
of the soviets to admit that they're
party organs whose only job it is to
carry water for politicians if if you
wrote a hollywood script you took it to
a big print a studio producer in los
angeles you said here's my script of a
completely
propagandistic
news media that all they ever do is
shill for the dominant regime and you
brought them this headline
in this context gas going through the
roof cost of everything going up 40-year
record high inflation and you brought
them the headline america just got a
hundred dollar a month raise
thank you biden for for these gas these
gas prices that you can see with your
own eyes you gotta pay for them out of
your wallet they're really secretly
they're really low
because two plus two equals five you
would be laughed out of the room they
would say it's two on the nose
you've got to you've got to cut it out
americans can tell
okay the joke is not on us
they think the joke is on us they're in
the editorial room teehee let's convince
let's convince all those hoy poloy
idiots that actually the gas is cheaper
teehee will pull their eyes no the
joke's not on us they are the joke cnn
is the joke they're the punch line okay
americans
recognize this stuff they are sick of
the propaganda that is why we cheer when
cnn's ratings go down it's why we cheer
when one of the most
one of the least bearable i was going to
say most unbearable but i get one of the
least bearable most tedious figures on
cnn brian stelter
just got canned and it brought back this
this montage
that tells you everything you need to
know about our establishment press
this brand new research by gallup says
american trust in the mass media is at
its lowest point since 2016 and near a
record low overall jeff zucker has
announced his immediate resignation as
the president of cnn this comes amid an
investigation into what jeff zucker
calls a consensual relationship what
happened and where cnn goes from here
you were caught masturbating on camera
you since then have been on leave from
cnn do i have all that right um you got
it all right sad to say the biggest
media story this weekend it's the firing
of chris cuomo from this network cnn
late wednesday a lawyer contacted cnn
with a sexual misconduct complaint about
cuomo joining me now the man who accused
don lemon of sexual assault his accuser
claims lemon started rubbing himself but
the even bigger point i think is about
what the press is is it produced by
reporters or by repeaters repeaters are
the talk radio shouters they're on tv
and radio telling the same story every
day president trump president trump
president trump trump trump trump trump
trump trump trump trump trump donald
trump donald trump telling the same
story every day same story every day so
what are are we the reporters or the
repeaters obviously the the people at
cnn are the repeaters they repeat
whatever the regime wants them to say
and occasionally
occasionally they have to face some
consequences from that because the
people can recognize that this is all
ridiculous they can see right through it
not just because they go to the gas pump
and they realize wait a second i'm not
saving money on gas cnn lied to me i'm
actually spending a lot more money i
guess that's not the only reason i think
the other reason that people started to
wake up to just how terrible the
establishment media is
is because of the internet because there
was a period
where
people really did trust
the establishment press those three news
networks that you would get on tv they
would trust walter cronkite i don't know
why they did walter cronkite was a
radical leftist he was a member of the
world federalists he was he lost us the
vietnam war
the guy was
not balanced not moderate not centrist
at all he was far on the left and yet
people said oh i trust walter cronkite
and now people say whatever happened to
walter cronkite even some of the other
ones later on in the 80s and the 90s tom
brokaw i trusted tom brokaw these days
though i don't know what changed is it
that the news anchor has changed
no i think it's that technology changed
i think the biggest reason that people
no longer have any faith in the
establishment press
is not even not even that the the anchor
has changed all that much it's that
people can now go on the internet and
look it up when you hear something from
the establishment press instead of back
in the old days say before the mid 90s
when you'd hear it and maybe you'd say
huh that doesn't sound quite right but
anyway i have no idea of figuring out if
it's true or not so okay moving on with
my life
now after the internet you can say hold
on wait gas is cheaper now under joe
biden
oh no obviously it's not it's actually
65 more expensive okay and this is true
even for political issues that are less
obvious than the price of gas i'm glad
you like that clip now you know we hit a
million subscribers i'm so pleased i'm
really thrilled about the million
subscribers i get the nice gold play
button it's very very cool you've got to
head on over though and ring this bell
and
get the notifications and subscribe
because i want to hit a billion
subscribers so do it now thank you
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]